thank you
I'm Dave Rubin and we've got a special
Thursday Round Table Extravaganza for
you it's just like the Friday Roundtable
extravaganzas except it's on Thursday
and joining me today are the co-hosts of
the upcoming brand new illusion of
consensus podcast former Reuben report
guest RAV Aurora and Dr J bhattacharya
rob J good to see you guys thanks for
having us Dave yeah it's great to be
here so if all goes well the podcast
will debut next week and I wanted to
give you guys a chance to do a little
bit of what you're going to be doing on
the podcast which is a lot of debunking
of nonsense and the expert class so
that's what we're going to be diving
into uh today I thought real quick
before we do it and I've got one ad uh
maybe if each of you could just take 30
seconds or so just kind of give me the
Genesis of why you guys wanted to do
this together and then we'll go from
there Dr J why don't you go first
well for me uh it's really fun to be
able to talk with a bright young
journalist and uh because one of the key
things I think that's been that's gone
on during the pandemic is you had
experts on high to telling people this
is the consensus when often it wasn't
often misleading people creating this
illusion and it's actually a young
journalist like Rob and and uh
podcasters and others citizen scientists
who who pushed back effectively so to me
like to cooperate with Rob is really uh
quite an honor Rob yeah yeah no it's
it's a thrill to collaborate with Jay on
this I think throughout the pandemic
one thing that has become really clear
is that there is this kind of Illusion
of consensus uh hence our title on a
number of issues and how
um you know the nuances and the
complexities of various issues whether
it's masking vaccines mandates lockdowns
Etc there's far more nuance and far more
diversity of opinion on those issues
than one would seem to believe by just
judging the mainstream media where they
select certain experts instead of others
and so it becomes sort of unquestionable
or it becomes the sort of monolith that
you can't question when you know given
set of experts support lockdowns or
vaccine mandates or mass mandates but in
reality there's far more debate on those
issues and you know Jay and I first met
I think September of 2021 when I first
interviewed him for an article and
before that point I was trusting the
mainstream experts I didn't know much
about what I was talking about and then
I talked to Jay and I'm like wait hold
on I thought these things were just
universally true I thought all
scientists believe that you know one
percent of people are going to die from
kova that masks Work That vaccine
mandates are a good idea but whoa whoa
hold on I've been hypnotized so I very
quickly kind of course corrected and
shifted my perspective on this and so JJ
and I are gonna examine the sort of
Illusion of consensus in the pandemic
but also in other areas potentially
um Psychiatry psychology
um
Etc so we look forward to uh
collaborating on this all right well
we're going to hit a couple of the type
of topics you guys are going to be
talking about with a little bit of that
nuance and diversity of ideas let me
talk to you guys about Cozy Earth real
quick and then we'll get to it do you
want your mom bragging about your
incredibly thoughtful Mother's Day gift
well I've got two words for you cozy
Earth the softest most luxurious and
responsibly sourced bedding and
loungewear on the planet cozy Earth
crafts luxury goods that transform your
lifestyle they're luxuriously cozy
loungewear is made from temperature
regulating viscous to Bam from bamboo
and is made to fit every body type from
soft crew socks to stretch knit tees
cozy Earth has your leisure wear covered
transform your bathroom into a spa with
Cozier plush towels as well as their new
premium waffle towel collection after a
long day of fighting for freedom and
curbing Joe Biden's radical woke agenda
there's nothing that I love more than
resting on my cozy Earth bed sheets I
seriously love these sheets cozy Earth
is having a huge Mother's Day sale going
on right now save up to 35 percent with
promo code Dave at cozyearth.com just
enter code Dave at checkout for 35 off
your order and now back to me all right
let's dive right into it because uh it
seems to me that many of the people
regardless of what country you are in
the people who quote unquote lead us
have led us in really really awful ways
I'd put Justin Trudeau just about at the
top of that list and this week he's
basically saying he never forced anyone
to get vaccinated
misinformation and disinformation is
carrying people to believe things that
are
untrue
and vaccinations is a perfect example of
it
like any
modern bit of medical
advancements there are
potential side effects in vaccinations
and there you know are people who've
probably gotten very sick from
vaccinations on the billions of people
who've been vaccinated against covet
over the past few years
and the idea that people can fly in the
face of science well individuals are
allowed to make their own choices there
may be all sorts of different reasons
why someone is hesitant to get
vaccinated but I make a distinction I
have always have
between someone choosing for personal
reasons
to choose not to get vaccinated
and someone deliberately
using misinformation
to mislead and scare other people with
so-called facts that aren't facts at all
and all of the scientists and the
medical experts and the researchers not
just in Canada but around the world
understood that vaccination was going to
be the way through this
and therefore while not forcing anyone
to get vaccinated I chose to make sure
that all the incentives and all the
protections were there to encourage
Canadians to get vaccinated and that's
exactly what they did
Jay let me start with you on this one I
mean he's rewriting history in real time
it is a complete lie that he was not
forcing people to get vaccinated ask any
of the Canadian truckers and the people
whose bank accounts got Frozen and the
Litany of other things that happened in
Canada but there's also a certain
condescension with him and smugness that
I think gets to the point that you
mentioned up top about this Elite Class
that thinks that they should not be
questioned now he somehow thinks oh you
know people should make choices for
themselves just not the misinformation
Specialists but it's completely the
reverse of what he pushed on Canadians
for three years
I mean even in that clip the the one
substantive point he tried to make which
is that uh the side effects are rare
well I mean rare according to who uh
there was a re-analysis of the Pfizer
and moderna trials a very careful one uh
done by uh Joe Fryman Peter Doshi and
some of their colleagues that found that
that the serious adverse event rate from
the vaccines in the randomized trials
themselves during that first two months
of that of that trial was one in 800.
that's a pretty high serious adverse
event rate for a vaccine that that's
deployed in Mass I mean it's normally
something like one in a million is that
is that correct I mean that would be
that would be a pretty safe vaccine one
in a million would be pretty safe
vaccine I mean the thing about is is
Dave is like you know it's it's it
should have been a nuanced thing where
you talk with your doctor about it right
so like if you're an older person
um you you put up with some of the
higher risk because you get this
enormous benefit of reductions in
mortality risk from covet right so I
that's why I advocated for vaccines for
older people because I thought it would
be a good idea on that not that would be
forced to do it but like because on that
it would save the lives of older people
for younger people it's a very different
calculus right a lot of young men got
myocarditis for taking this vaccine and
what benefit do they get from the
vaccine itself when covid uh the the
death rate from covid in young men is
very very very low
um so I just I think was one of these
things where like he's just he's
obviously gaslighting people and and
what I find really offensive is this is
this implication that he didn't coerce
people he didn't force people just
because he didn't hold people down and
Jab them with with a with a needle by
himself doesn't mean he didn't coerce me
he he violated the civil rights of a
tremendous number of Canadians they
couldn't even travel within their own
country if they were unvaccinated
quite literally you could not get on
trains Rob you're unvaccinated you are a
Canadian and I say that with all due
irony because uh Dr bhattachary is in
California which is the Canada of
America I'm here in free Florida uh but
when you see your prime minister
gaslighting the country like that I mean
how do you feel about that
yeah well it's potentially misleading
what he's saying because In that clip he
sounds fairly reasonable like if those
things were followed right you know we
didn't force people there are lots of
vaccine Adverse Events lots of people
have gotten sick and I make this
distinction between people who don't
want to get it and other people who are
you know down the conspiratorial
anti-vaxx cult
Etc all of that is reasonable but his
policies were not reasonable right mean
here in Canada I mean I remember then I
think this was around the first time I
spoke to Jay in September of 2021 right
vaccine mandates were brought into
effect and I couldn't exercise at a gym
couldn't go to a wedding couldn't go to
large restaurants large Gatherings
couldn't leave the country you know you
know my my family's from India they
wanted to go visit relatives they
couldn't go to India I couldn't go to
India we couldn't do so many different
things that we wanted to do simply
because we chose not to get this
experimental vaccine and so for Trudeau
now to to say in this clip that you know
he took all these reasonable measures
and how he allowed People Choice well
again similar to what Jay said obviously
you know cops weren't at our door
shoving needles in our arms but if you
worked in a federally regulated industry
you couldn't go to your job I mean I
know people who were working online and
they couldn't even resume their job
because the way the mandates were
federally forced down it was really
strict and really Draconian and so
people even working virtually couldn't
return to their jobs and so
you know all of this has been a Great
Awakening you know for me because I I
really underestimated how much the
government can clamp down on a society
and enforce these Draconian measures and
it's it's it's it's really shocked me
how many people still go along with it
um when when Trudeau is using this you
know this kind of illusory veil of love
and compassion and inclusivity yet
we had some of the most Draconian
coveted measures in the world and as you
guys know I mean at least from an
American perspective most of the blue
State Governors who did all of this
stuff got re-elected in some cases by
landslides Jay what would do you see a
sort of silver lining in that his
rhetoric at least did shift so he he
sort of has given up on most of the
Draconian stuff and even if he's lying
and rewriting history now at least we
got there I mean I know that's not a
great comfort but it's I suppose
something there's a French philosopher
who has this dictum love roshuko he says
uh that hypocrisy is the homage that
that Vice pays to Virtue
um which that's that's it right there
that's it yeah I mean he has to pretend
right because the problem is like what
they did is just in defensible Dave it
just it's just not it and you you look
back and you say boy that was those were
crazy times those were crazy times
because people like Trudeau imposed
crazy policies that didn't protect
people from kovid I mean Sweden had as
among the lowest all-cause excess death
rates in the world lower than Canada and
they didn't follow all of these crazy
mandate policies these lockdown policies
they didn't close schools it's a real
problem for a political leader like
Trudeau who adopted these uh I mean you
know there's a story of of a pizza shop
owner uh in Toronto I think whose pizza
shop got shut down because he allowed an
unvaccinated person to come in and eat
um I mean it I mean you have policies
like that we're on completely
unnecessary to actually protect the
populace when you look at the Swedish
example he has to do something like he
has to I mean I guess what he chose to
do is lie if I were his advisor I would
tell him just just
fess up be honest like say look I I made
tremendous mistakes I I I've learned
from them and here's what I want to do
going forward
um you'd at least would you have the the
decency to to honor the people you've
harmed when you did that
um see this is just it I don't know who
it convinces
you know Jordan Peterson's line on
Trudeau is that he simply cannot utter
one single statement that is true that
he's basically so deep in the nonsense
that that's where he's at uh RAV finish
us up on Justin Trudeau from a Canadian
perspective is this guy is I mean is uh
has he lost any cred with the people or
I know he only got 30 some odd percent
of the vote but he said he is still in
power whether we like it or not yeah I
was going to mention one other thing
that some people might miss you know in
the clip he says well yes you know there
have been vaccine Adverse Events and
some people have gotten very very sick I
don't think that was the line he used a
year ago or two years ago right this is
this is kind of a newer admission and
you know it's cloaked in this well we
gave it to billions of people obviously
some people are going to get it now
that's true with every medicine and
every medical intervention but as Jay
mentioned this vaccine seems to have
um the highest adverse event rate we've
seen in the history of vaccines in terms
of a vaccine that's been broadly used
um and you know pushed by the government
and whatnot and on my own sub stack one
of the stories that I wrote in I think
this was late uh late last year was a 38
year old law enforcement officer I'm
also a South Asian background like me
and he was forced to get vaccinated in
order to maintain his job in law
enforcement because of the federal
mandates pushed by Trudeau and after his
second Pfizer dose shortly after uh a
few days like in the middle of the night
he was
you know panting having shortness of
breath
um you've got horrible chest pain he
thought he was fine he was just going to
brush it off and this guy's really fit
he's working out all the time he's
um incredibly healthy calls the
ambulance and they just you know take a
rush into the hospital and the
cardiologist said that he was lucky to
have been alive because he got vaccine
myocarditis which could have resulted in
an immediate heart attack and as this
person told me this was just one
Hospital in Victoria BC British Columbia
and he said something like he was the
third or fourth myocarditis the vaccine
myocarditis patient within the last like
30 to 60 days in this one Hospital alone
so you know for for Trudeau to say now
that you know lots of people have gotten
sick from you know the vaccine like of
course this is what you happen this is
what happens when you indiscriminately
push you know one medical intervention
on everybody and sort of a you know a
one-size-fits-all policy without being
honest like hey for young men there's
this risk for kids there's a far lower
risk of covid and so we should
prioritize elderly people and let anyone
under 40 50 or 60 like whatever you want
let them choose what they want to do and
not force this medical intervention that
is known to produce serious cardiac
outcomes in a minority of young males
who get it right none of that was
considered it was just as many vaccines
as possible and as many arms as possible
without any kind of nuance or personal
choice for the record I would be for not
manding mandating any vaccine for anyone
under 100 years old that's my own
personal libertarian Utopia but let's
move on to to the sort of rewriting of
History because it's not just that it's
happening in Canada it's happening right
here in the United States I want to read
a tweet that uh Jay you sent out a
couple days ago apparently president
Trump is attacking Governor Ron DeSantis
as a lockdown Governor it is a
ridiculous charge I spoke with Governor
DeSantis in July 21 about his thinking
on kovid lockdowns open schools Etc on
my otherwise neglected YouTube channel
and I want to show you a little clip of
you talking to DeSantis about just that
in the population from uh from
reinfection from from being exposed to
the disease uh so can you talk about
antibody in Florida we've been uh we hit
probably 25 on our testing now those
aren't scientifically representative
it's people that want to go in it now
has kind of gone down just because you
know we have less prevalence uh the
protection is still there but the
antibodies may not be popping in these
tests
um and so that's one thing to look at
but then there may be other things can
you just summarize what the state of
play is on that so the news is actually
very very good it looks like the the
disease is not as lethal as we thought
it's for young people really uh much
less lethal even than the flu
for um for uh if you a large fraction of
the population a substantial fraction of
the population seems to have been
infected and not died from it
um and that's protect but providing some
protection in the population from uh
from reinfection from from being exposed
to the disease
all right I just want to clean something
up real quick so you had a conversation
with him in in 21 on your YouTube
channel that is from a year before so
September of 2020 that's why I wanted to
run that clip because even back then you
were you were really one of the leading
voices on everybody calm down let's see
what's going on here and uh and Trump
seems to be rewriting that in real time
I don't really understand I mean I guess
politics just frustrates me I'm not sure
how people put up with it I mean what
Trump is trying to do paint uh the
governor as a lockdown Governor is just
deeply an unfair charge I mean I think
the state did lock down in March of 2020
up mainly because Trump uh and uh Pence
sent around Debbie Burks all around the
country that's scaring The Living
Daylights out of every almost every
single governor and uh so the state did
lock down but I think uh that DeSantis
was among the earliest to open up in May
starting in May of 2020 he called me in
September of 2020 uh before that clip he
just called me up out of the blue we
talked for two hours Dave and uh it was
remarkable he had read a whole bunch of
papers he he like he knew the footnotes
of papers I was I was floored and you
know on we had that Round Table uh where
he was he led the discussion uh you know
and we uh right shortly after that round
table which included press it was it was
put up on YouTube
um he opened the state he opened the
rest of the state and I seen him also
personally apologize there's this one
clip which I remember of him in a
pressed on press conference where he's
talking about having closed down uh sort
of isolating older people so that they
couldn't even visit with family members
and he told a story about somebody who
who told who didn't get to see their
parents before her mom before they died
he he broke down crying an apology for
that he said I can't believe that I did
this uh that did you know and I'm I'm
sorry I mean it's remarkable politician
that would do something like that just
admit that kind of error and they never
did it again and by the way by the way
he subsequently has passed into law that
that type of thing can never happen
again that you would have rights whether
it's your spouse or parent or child to
get into the hospital room so everyone
makes mistakes and it's about the people
that kind of correct it uh Rob on the on
the sort of political side of this is it
just like one of those things like all
right guys are running for president and
it's just going to get nasty
yeah yeah I I think so I mean we know
what Trump's been putting out recently
you know a lot of crazy allegations you
know I mean the way he talks about Ron
DeSantis you know Ron Des sanctimonious
or meatball run or whatever whatever all
these things I mean
I I think he's just using whatever dirt
he can and just throwing it you know to
sandus's way I mean it's
I I I'm not sure what the prospects are
for for Trump or DeSantis
um but I think I think DeSantis has a
lot of Promise in the future given how
he's handled kovid I mean him and Dr
Joseph latipo you know the head Surgeon
General of Florida I mean I I've written
a few times to tell they're leading with
the best example that I've seen across
the world I mean you know what Dr latipo
I mean he's always promoting you know
Holistic Health Fitness supplements you
know these kind of things and
recommending against mRNA vaccination I
believe for men under 40 I think was
their uh recent advisory uh guidelines
so you know they've been at the
Forefront of uh examining the MRNA
vaccine safety and being honest about
the risks and benefits so you know you
know my hats are off to Dr latipo and
and DeSantis for for how they've handled
this and by the way when Dr latipo
posted the the study on men under 40
with myocarditis uh Twitter the old
regime of Twitter censored it went back
up a couple days later and obviously
things are different with Elon I want to
show you one response uh by DeSantis in
the last couple days about some of the
stuff that Trump's been uh saying about
his response leaders take the bull by
the horns and make the decisions for
themselves they don't subcontract out
their leadership to health bureaucrats
like Dr fauci
there are some that want to open up
almost now if we disagree with it we're
not going to let them open but I didn't
like to see spas
at this early stage and or did the
doctors going ahead and leapfrogging
into phases where you should not be I
would advise him as a health official
and as a physician not to do that
Jay I know you don't want to get bogged
down too much in the political part of
this but if if Trump had been president
at the time and you were advising him
instead of fauci do you think there are
moments that you would have really gone
in the other direction or do you think
that it just fauci listens to his own
experts too and that that really gets to
the thesis again of why you guys are
doing this podcast I mean we don't have
to like uh play hypotheticals we can
actually see what happened right so we
had in July of 2020 uh we had president
Trump who I think his instincts were
looked that this is too excessive around
July 2020 it was already too excessive
why are we locking down he brought in
Scott Atlas to advise him Scott and I
were in close contact when he when Scott
was in the white house we were sharing
papers we were discussing you know new
new papers are coming out nearly every
day and Scott routinely expressed his
frustration to me about his his
inability to get across to Tony fauci
and Debbie Burks at basic scientific
facts that were coming becoming clearer
and clear about immunity about the age
age you know the high risk for older
people the low risk for younger people
um the the necessity of focused
protection the necessity of opening
schools
um you know all of that he was unable to
get across and the question I had in my
mind is why did President Trump who
actually I think had the right instincts
in the middle of 2020 when he hired
Scott Atlas leave in place people like
Tony fauci and Debbie Brooks to
undermine his own strategy he's the
president United States he he has to
take responsibility for the policies
that he put in place for the leaders he
enabled to make those decisions um and
you know I just it's it's one of these
things I I don't I don't enter politics
because I don't I don't really I mean I
think in public health we have to uh
reach everybody no matter what their
politics are
um but I mean when when you when I look
at that I just it just I I just imagine
imagine what on that wonder what what if
what if he had really enabled Scott
Atlas to be the leader that he was he
wanted to be rather than allowing Tony
to have to take the center stage over
and over again
you know one one of the themes obviously
that we've all been talking about over
the last couple years is how do you find
people to trust so I want to shift a
little bit here because RAV I know one
guy that you and I I would say trusted
fairly intimately over the last couple
years on most things uh was Sam Harris
and Sam Harris has had I think just some
a series of big I would say political
blunders something to that effect uh and
he was on a podcast recently talking
about how we should really only listen
to experts and I thought it was rather
enlightening take a look
there's we're swimming in a sea of
misinformation where you've got people
who are moving the opinions of millions
of others
who who should not have an opinion on
these topics like there's no there is no
scenario in which you should be getting
your opinion about vaccine safety or or
climate change or
uh the war in Ukraine or anything else
that we might want to talk about from
Candace Owens right it's just like it
like like she she's not a relevant
expert on any of those topics and what's
more she doesn't seem to care right and
and she's living in a culture that has
that has
Amplified that not carrying into a
business model an effective business
model right so it's just it's um and
that there's something very trumpy and
about
rabbits it's kind of bizarre because I
think we're all in agreement here the
experts whether they're the political
experts or the science experts or the
cult whatever experts have gotten almost
everything wrong lately so there are
reasons that people turn to other normal
people
yeah yeah yeah first of all I just want
to say I I still you know really like
Sam and he has a fantastic meditation
app that I use every day I think he's
done incredible work in extracting the
greatest kind of spiritual wisdom from
the East you know in his time when he
was in India and bringing that to the
West uh bringing traditional you know
Buddhist and Hindu practices and kind of
in a universal uh message on his waking
up app but all of that aside
he just miserably failed in my opinion
and I've told him that and we've
privately corresponded at Great length
about these things and to some success
but to some failure although I do have
uh you know I honestly do have hope for
him because as more and more information
comes out um it's going to be very very
hard to uh defend his positions that
he's taken in the past but you know Sam
says that we shouldn't be listening to
people like Candace Owens or others on
vaccine safety and vaccine efficacy but
at the height of of 2021 in the summer
when vaccines were rolled out on his
podcast he was saying the case for
getting vaccinated is absolutely
clear-cut everybody should be getting
this thing right away as soon as
possible
um you know there's there's so many
different stories that he told there's
one incident where he was at a
restaurant and there were unvaccinated
waiters around him and he basically said
that these people are nothing but hosts
of deranged right-wing conspiracy theory
when in retrospect I mean you know those
young men might have been smart not to
get vaccinated depending on the health
status and whatnot but you know
the way in which he spoke about vaccines
and the sources that he used like he had
he had on Eric topple in that podcast
and he's had on Nicholas for stakis you
know both those figures especially Eric
topel have continually gotten so many
things wrong I mean people can go look
this up on on Dr vinay prashad you know
great guy on his sub stack he we
recently just put out an article on Eric
tople and pointed out like 10 different
like basic errors that he's made in
interpreting studies on Long covet on
vaccines on covet causing strokes and
heart attacks right Eric topple has
proven to be completely unreliable and
erroneous in many of his positions yet
he was kind of the The Chosen Guru by
Sam and used as sort of justification
for things that Sam pushed well in
retrospect and continuing to this day
you know Sam refuses to listen to you
know people like Jay and others who have
dissented on this topic and have instead
attacked him and I think Jay and I we
spoke about this in our recent uh
podcast episode yeah I actually I want
to get I want to get to a clip of that
but actually Jay you're a Stanford guy I
know so much of sort of the intellect
Elite comes out of Stanford how did you
not fall into this trap
well I mean I think one thing uh listen
I clip that I think is a mistake that
Sam makes and a lot of people make
um there's on one side there are facts
that are difficult to know like the way
you learn about those facts is by debate
scientific debate among people who have
some expertise sometimes even people who
don't look to have the relevant
expertise have important things to say
about facts on on the other side you
have values about what to do with those
facts
uh like someone like Sam Harris has his
values and he has his knowledge his view
of facts he's entitled to them someone
like Candace Owens has her her knowledge
uh about about the about the facts and
also her her values I think are quite at
odds with with uh with someone like Sam
Harris you combine those together and
you may have a very different opinion
about what to do about about you know X
Y or Z it doesn't that's not
misinformation that's just that's just
how humans like make action make
decisions is by combining facts with
their values and then then making
recommendations it's it's kind of it's
It's to me it's like the height of
hubris to say well okay I I don't think
that you should listen to this other
person it really most of it is not about
facts most of it's about differences in
values
um that that I think Candace and Sam
have
um I I don't I don't I I mean I think
it's one thing like if it's one thing if
Sam is going to say well let's look at
the scientific evidence and here's
here's what this says and that says and
here's what this expert says and and
it's one thing to try to do a balanced
assessment of the scientific evidence in
a lot of areas of science there's a
range of of ideas hypotheses that are
possible given the data it's not right
for him to say oh I know the truth so
much that I can just condemn uh this
other individual as being completely
unqualified I mean it's not the
qualifications it's whether the facts
are right or wrong how does that combine
with values how do you connect with your
audience do you persuade people based on
the the connections I mean all of that
is like very complicated and I just I
find I find myself uh you know I I just
can't do this I can't I can't look at
Sam Harris talk looking down on people
and that's just bad Public Health I
think yeah it's really disappointing and
I just want to say again because I've
said it a few times when I've referenced
him on my podcast I'm not trying to do
this gratuitously or to attack him it's
really just if you're part of the public
discourse then people are going to push
back on on some of the other stuff you
might say his uh feelings about this
have been sort of religious or cult-like
which I guess would be a bit ironic but
let's shift for a second because he left
uh Sam this gives me a perfect segue
actually Sam left Twitter because of
Elon Musk he had thanked Jack Dorsey for
Banning Trump way back when which was a
bit of an odd move uh but then he left
Twitter once Elon Musk took over got a
little video of Elon and uh what he's
doing at Twitter these days the same
standard should apply to me as applies
to everyone on Twitter just as it does
on positive or negative
so what do you do same for everyone
another thing that that a lot of
traditional journalists don't like is
they don't like being put on the same
platform as the average citizen they
don't like their voice being it's the
same they're pretty mad about that yes I
uh there are several news organizations
who don't like your push for
democratization and what they believe is
the devaluing of the badges because they
were differentiated so is that just a
moment does
just a moment in time
no that's deliberate I think it's very
important for
to to elevate citizen journalism I think
it's very important to hear the voice of
the people the actual voice of the
people not the filtered voice of the
people and let the people choose the
narrative and let the people determine
the truth
and not five editors in Chiefs of major
Publications
do you do you want to know what's really
going on or do you want their opinion
you know it's a handful of people I
think I think we want to know the voice
of the people the true voice of the
people this does get us to that starting
point of the elites versus the people
and RAV there's an awful lot of Elites
and formerly blue check journalists who
are very upset and not willing to pay
eight dollars to still have that blue
check and you know get some of the
benefits thereof
yeah well Dave you know we should we
should really hold our thoughts and
prayers for the the blue check mark
genocide all these people who can't
afford eight dollars a month I mean I
mean how many how many Spotify or
Netflix or crave or HBO whatever
subscriptions these people have and how
much time are they spending on these
things I mean eight dollars a month is I
mean it's I think you said it's a price
of a coffee or whatever like the the
Meltdown over these little things on
Twitter this is the point where I get
where like I'm looking at all these
people melting down and I'm like I need
to get off Twitter because this is a
fake reality this is like a
hallucination this is not real this is
like this is like the most trivial of
trivial problems and I need to go
outside and like you know touch the dirt
or something and do something in their
real hands because people are whining
about eight dollars a month but other
than that like what Elon Musk just says
uh in this clip is absolutely right I
mean this explains the rise of sub stack
how leading Publications you know
throughout the pandemic especially and
in other issues have gotten things
completely wrong I mean the Atlantic the
New York Times on lockdowns mask
mandates vaccines
Etc they've gotten these issues so wrong
and they've failed to hold big Pharma
accountable for what they've done you
know Pfizer and moderna and the CDC and
the FDA and misleading the public and so
that you know that explains why so many
people are now subscribing to sub Stacks
where you know independent journalists
like myself can freely write about
vaccines and write about mandates
without any fear of an editor uh you
know editorializing or changing things
and I'll just quickly say too like in my
experience even writing for a couple of
major like conservative leading
Publications I couldn't write about
vaccine mandates even I mean I had some
editors who despite being kind of
right-leaning or libertarian they were
still like no no we're not we're not
going to publish anything negative about
vaccines or and I'm like what you know
this is the data you know myocarditis or
whatever and they're like no no we're
not going to do that and I'm like really
like okay if I was in New York Times I
would expect that but some of these
other Publications have kind of sold out
on this issue too so that pushed this
sort of migration to sub stack on my
part and to launching this podcast as
well with Jay
uh Jay I assume that elon's words are
music to your ears because obviously you
were Shadow banned and then suspended
and then ultimately banned band from
Twitter by the old regime reinstated by
Elon uh do you have confidence that that
this thing's going to work out properly
and that he can you know keep it in
defense of free speech and the rest of
it
well we'll see it's it's difficult I
mean I think a lot of uh what what you
have to understand is a lot of the
censorship by social media a lot of the
the sort of like narrative enforcement
by by uh uh you know the press
a lot of that actually is actually at
the best of the government I've been
involved with this lawsuit uh Missouri
versus Biden brought by the Missouri and
Louisiana attorney general's offices uh
I'm represented by the new civil
liberties Alliance
um and what we found is that there was a
vast censorship uh apparatus set up by
the federal government including these
including like the surgeon general's
office uh including you know people
including the NIH and there's there's
just and including the White House
itself sending messages threatening
social media about what to ban and who
to ban it's almost inconceivable that it
wasn't also uh I mean you look you have
those newspapers like the New York Times
essentially reinforcing The Narrative
that Tony facci wants
um a lot of what we saw this sort of
univocal support for lockdowns and all
that all that and then censorship and a
delegitimization of people who opposed
um was at the behest of the government
it wasn't just simply social media doing
it by itself
um what Elon Musk has done in Twitter is
actually quite Brave I mean he's
essentially telling the government to go
take a flying hike at uh flying leap
whereas like you know you look at
Facebook you still have this censorship
regime going on
you know when I was at Twitter uh they I
sat down with all these engineers and
they opened up everything for me you
know there were certain tabs they
couldn't click with personal and you
know personal emails that sort of thing
but they showed me everything and it's
it's incredible because Jack Dorsey
testified under oath that Twitter didn't
Shadow ban the entire system was built
on Shadow Banning and tags and all of
the all of those other things Jay can
you just bring us home on one last thing
here and then we got to run uh you were
last time I saw you was a few months ago
at uh covid panel that Governor DeSantis
put together Brett Weinstein was there a
few other people uh what's happening
with that and uh I I guess do you do you
think uh anything will actually come of
it
well we're about to meet I think uh in
early May um you know it's it's it's
it's one of these things where like
science Works frustratingly slowly so
you're we're just working through
various issues and and uh uh related to
vaccination uh uh Health policy going
forward
um and you know we're just it's a it's a
robust discussion so uh uh stay tuned I
mean we'll we'll have uh we'll
eventually have some reports and various
things it's but it but it's a it's a
slow process Dave
I thought you could do science just like
that there you go RAV J great seeing you
guys thank you so much and uh guys no
post game show today because I'm
actually across the world in the in the
other Holy Land not Florida I'm in
Israel right now and we'll have more
videos for you in the next couple days
thanks